hey I'm Patrick Jenelle it's Valentine's  Day which means it's time to do a little  shopping if you're looking for a  Valentine's Day gift for a lady GQ and I  have teamed up to come up with a few  ideas that are sure to make her happy  now everyone likes to take a selfie and  that's why every lady needs an iphone 6s  the camera on this thing is legit it's  such a good gift that you'll be tempted  to keep it for yourself but you should  give it to someone awesome next for the  active woman in your life we have these  lululemon yoga pants these things are  awesome they're super comfortable for  yoga or any type of workout but honestly  she can wear them anywhere focus your Qi  on these last but not least if you want  more power to your pixel this fuji x100  t is the way to go if sleek stylish has  a vintage look and if i were to get  appointment shoot this would be the one  for me those are my pics from me and GQ  happy Valentine's Day